have you been in the midwest i really
like minnesota minnesota really probably
my favorite state i've been to in the us
i got deported from there
thanks minnesota
well i don't know
i had a very warm welcome in minnesota
oh
you said they were really really nice
though when they were deporting you
though no they weren't nice because
they weren't nice about it at least they
were like hey it's not your fault man it
happens all the time kind of thing but
you also have to uh fly immediately to
amsterdam and then
from to tokyo are you allowed to say why
you got deported is that like something
you want to talk about oh just visa
mix-ups basically i mean like you've got
the wrong visa right yeah basically i
had the wrong visa apparently i i asked
the uh the immigration officer in
minnesota he was like yeah this this
happens all the [ __ ] times like it's
like you are definitely not in the wrong
for not knowing this [ __ ] like it is
really confusing um but he's like just
go home get this particular visa and
then you'll be good for like the next 10
years at least sounds really cool saying
you got deported yeah until you get
deported yeah yeah i'm sure getting
deported wasn't cool yeah no
getting deported wasn't cool but the
fact that i literally flew around the
world in 48 hours yeah you just did a
[ __ ] speed run i i did basically
speed ran like around the world yeah
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] took them 80
days the first time you know what i mean
you did it
just get deported bro
around the word deportation hack
i used the deported skip
i
went to the us i didn't know you needed
the visa right i was like what
so so what happened
we didn't need a visa before
no we did we needed the esther
that that was introduced pretty recently
yeah the esther before the before the
esther you didn't need it yeah the first
time went to america you didn't need an
esther how long ago was this esther was
like 10 15 years ago yeah something like
that it was within my lifetime that the
uh the the
legislation changed well because you
know you've been traveling through
europe all my life and i just assumed
you just turn out where you want to go
oh well yeah i mean that makes sense so
i didn't know that and so i booked my
flight to the us this this when the
esther was a thing yeah which is
[ __ ] because america can come to the
uk no no no documentation needed just a
passport oh yeah when we when we have to
go to america we have to get this esther
nonsense right yeah so i'm i'm i'm
getting all my stuff ready this is my
first flight ever to america i'm on my
own oh my god and then it's like
midnight and my flight like 9am my dad
my dad came in my room he's like did you
get the visa i'm like what
what do you mean
yeah you gotta get a visa i'm like who
no one told me this how do i get the
visa i'm like 19 as well i've never
heard of this yeah when do i have to get
a visa yeah and luckily uh apparently
supposed to get it three days before
yeah three days uh but yeah like more
than three days before yeah but luckily
it came in 15 minutes yeah yeah i was
very lucky i also did that in japan as
well that was very yeah aki had to do
that at the airport once because like
she realized her esther had run out you
just have a really [ __ ] track record at
uh getting into countries so yeah i just
i i'm losing your passport before we go
to japan oh yeah i remember that i
totally forgot because it only lasts for
two years when you go to the us you have
to get from most countries and also
canada if you get one too yeah you just
apply for a thing called nesta cost 15
you do it online if your passport is
like normal you're like no criminal
record or anything you should get it in
like 15 minutes yeah like immediately
but do it three days just in case that's
why they suggest you um yeah and it
lasts two years and when i moved to
japan i was going to go to san francisco
and i totally forgot it expired until i
was on the way to the airport when i
realized it had expired so i was
applying for it on my phone yeah on the
way and luckily right before i was about
to check in i just got it oh nice i was
like nice that's gold split right there
yeah
yeah i told my company i'm like uh hey
uh i forgot to uh get the esther they
were like what
what and i was like yeah so i i applied
for it it should be fine we'll see i'll
see
we'll see
luckily it all worked out at least yeah
at least you weren't like on the plane
when you realized that yeah yeah yeah
it's weird though because they don't ask
me for it and they don't ask me for
their they don't ask you for the asked
at any point so i wonder is it just on
like a system they only ask you for it
when you're immigrating into the country
that you just landed
no they they asked they they should what
what uh airline did you fly with british
airways they never they've never asked
me for it because because i normally get
asked when i'm queuing up to check in
if if i have a visa yeah they know they
never asked me that because i really
really never thought maybe i'm just so
charming they're like no no no go in go
ahead go
of course there's chances you need to
excuse me sir do you have a visa to get
into our country
right now [ __ ]
no but like like especially coming from
having dual citizenship in a uk and
thailand yeah it's just like it just
makes me realize man we are very
privileged to have certain passports
because it it's it's it is literally
just some passports are completely
useless
yeah japan is like the most
op passport most powerful possible in
the world but yeah but no but only like
20 people have them here can you believe
that yeah the [ __ ] audacity and also
yeah it's there's so many like weird
other rules that come with it and also
and and again it's like yeah as you were
saying it's the most powerful possible
in the world and yet barely any japanese
people fly out of japan because the
tourism industry here is just so
powerful
i completely
i was just going to say that some some
pastors are like pretty op and
uh like that's that's that makes me
jealous of your japanese passport
because you can get in like
what what can japan get in without a
visa that the uk can't i'm sure there's
something i'm sure there's one place
i'll put it on the screen
obviously
i don't think about this but i think
like in the uk it's something like 70 to
80 people have a passport in america
it's like yeah it was so weird for me
going to a country and just like meeting
people without a passport yeah everyone
just has one in the uk yeah everyone i
know has one yeah in australia as well
like almost everyone has one yeah yeah i
guess i guess it's just like a
difference in culture right yeah like i
couldn't imagine not having a passport
what are you going to go and do in the
uk just go to like a field and be like
sick this is great vacation or i could
and also get a passport go to another
country and go to that field yeah
exactly but like you know they've seen
our beaches yeah
sure someone who's born up in brighton
oh we have amazing beaches
you want sand beaches no we got we've
got stone stones you can't even walk